jenkins is an open source automation
server which makes it easier to build
test and deploy software
in this course you'll learn how to build
a full devops pipeline using jenkins
lenode servers and other tools
gwen faraday is your teacher for this
course gwen is an experienced software
developer and she has created a bunch of
popular courses on both her own channel
and the free codecamp channel jenkins
can help developers automate their
software development process and improve
their productivity it can also help
users obtain a fresh build of their
software project more easily
jenkins is an important tool for
creating a devops pipeline
a devops pipeline is a set of processes
and tools that enable the continuous
delivery of software applications the
term devops is a combination of the
words development and operations
devops pipelines are used to automate
the build test and deploy phases of the
software development lifecycle the goal
of a devops pipeline is to make the
software development process more
efficient and effective
devops pipelines help to automate the
tedious and manual tasks that are often
involved in software development
this automation can help to speed up the
software development process and make it
more reliable
jenkins is a flexible tool that can be
used to create custom devops pipelines
and that's what you're going to learn
about in this course
so at the end consider leaving a comment
with something you learn in this course
hi everyone my name is gwen and in this
course on free code camp i'm going to be
building a full devops pipeline
using tools like jenkins lenode servers
for hosting our application as well as
our jenkins server we'll be using github
as our code repository
docker and docker hub and some related
tools now to follow along with this
tutorial you can see the app that i will
be using for deployments
on my faraday academy github
organization it's called the curriculum
app if you followed my youtube channel
you might have seen that i actually
built this application in maybe 50 or so
live streams a few years ago
there is also a readme here on github
where i have each step in the process
listed out as well as links and relevant
resources
and this architecture diagram of how
everything fits together in the process
jenkins is a tool used for automation
with continuous integration and
continuous deployment pipelines
the project started in 2004 so it's been
around for almost 20 years and it's
completely open source
right now
it claims that it's the most commonly
used automation server in software
development
so why would you want to use jenkins as
an app developer
it allows you to automatically watch for
certain events in your repository
and react to those events you can do
things like
build your code run scripts perform
testing
and then deploy your app if everything
passes
or reject the deployment if the test
fails
either way you will be able to see logs
of every step throughout the jenkins
pipeline and the results of the
deployment
jenkins can ensure that all of your
tests are run in the same environment or
as many environments as you want for
consistency
another benefit
is that jenkins has a very large
community that is amassed over almost
the last 20 years
so there are lots of tutorials and
community questions and answers that you
can find
another feature of jenkins is its
plug-in architecture to use jenkins
effectively you will want to install the
plugins that make sense for your project
these plugins can include options for
compiling or testing
they have a docker plug-in which we will
be using as well as a git plug-in that
allows us to watch our github repository
and react to changes
jenkins is self-hosted by default you
don't need to pay for an enterprise tier
this gives you a lot of options for
configuration
it's also a tool that has been proven to
scale since it's used by so many large
companies around the world
it's not just large companies that use
jenkins however many small or mid-sized
companies use this tool as well
why do companies use it many of them say
that it improves their software delivery
cycles by making them faster and more
performant
what are some of the benefits of using
jenkins versus other alternatives
there are plenty of new tools in the
cicd pipeline space
you could choose travis ci or circleci
there's also github actions
there's get lab ci and many more
some of the differences are that jenkins
is open source many of the other options
are not
a big one is that you can self-host
without paying for an enterprise plan
and you have total control over
configuration
one thing that might be helpful if
you're considering jenkins
as an option and comparing it to other
alternatives
is their jenkins youtube channel
they have a lot of information about
jenkins
and they also have this playlist
of real users of jenkins real companies
talking about why they chose jenkins
and what benefits they see from using it
we talked about some of the benefits now
let's talk about some of the cons or
potential drawbacks of using jenkins
so plugins i listed in the pros column
because there are hundreds of plugins
covering all different kinds of use
cases and you can usually find a plugin
for what you need in jenkins
you also have the option to
create one yourself
that can also be a drawback though since
you are relying on community supported
plugins that might not be updated
or documented well there can also be
some confusing overlap between plugins
since anyone can create their own
jenkins plugin
a common complaint of jenkins is the
outdated ui
more modern tools have interfaces that
are a little bit easier to use than the
standard jenkins interface
now jenkins does have a newer interface
that you can install as a plug-in and
use for a lot of things but not
everything and that is the blue ocean
plug-in
we're going to demo that in this
tutorial as well
another potential drawback
is that since it's been around for so
long
and it's community supported sometimes
the documentation or answers that you
find can be out of date
this is not an uncommon problem for
software tools in general
overall i think jenkins has pretty good
documentation but it is something to be
aware of
checking and making sure that the
documentation you are reading is up to
date with the version of jenkins that
you are using
another huge consideration to keep in
mind when choosing jenkins is that it's
completely self-hosted and maintained
unless you are using a third-party
solution to manage your jenkins server
you will be the one installing jenkins
keeping it up to date
managing the controller and agents and
all the different aspects of the jenkins
pipeline
and also ensuring security
which can be tricky sometimes using a
tool like jenkins where you need to
install so many different plugins to use
it
before we really dive in here i want to
make sure we're all on the same page by
defining some terms that i'll be using
in this tutorial
and common terms that you will see
when you are using jenkins as well
let's go over some of the terms that we
will be using in this tutorial just to
make sure everyone is on the same page
first we use the terms continuous
integration and continuous delivery
commonly abbreviated as cicd
favorite definition for continuous
integration actually comes from
atlassian
it says continuous integration is the
practice of automating the integration
of coding changes from multiple
contributors into a single software
project
developers can frequently merge code
changes into a central repository where
it builds and then the tests run
continuous integration is a precursor
for continuous delivery
continuous delivery is responsible for
packaging the app
and getting it ready to deploy using
automated build tools
this whole process is known as a
pipeline a pipeline is basically a
well-defined set of steps
that build test and deploy applications
automatically
it basically takes you through the
continuous integration and continuous
delivery processes
you will see that we also have a build
step in our pipeline that we are going
to be using
if you are new to development or have
only used something like javascript
maybe you aren't familiar with a build
step but generally the build step will
spin up an environment
compile code and create an executable if
that's necessary
when we talk about testing code
that is a step of the pipeline that will
run any unit end-to-end integration or
whatever other tests that are needed for
the application
to make sure that it's ready to deploy
into production if the tests pass
there are two other terms that are
jenkins specific here
the first is controller
and that's our main instance of jenkins
that is running
the jenkins controller is responsible
for
configuration key management
plugins and it's a centralized hub to
manage all of the agents connecting to
it
agents are usually containerized
environments that will run your pipeline
steps
these steps are also called a job
which means
some work that needs to be done the
jenkins controller is responsible for
assigning it to an agent
and then the agent will either spin up
and run all the steps of that job
through to failure or deployment
you can also set the agent to
just stay running
all the time instead of spinning up for
each job that you want to run
this is a simple diagram of the
architecture
for this tutorial so you can visualize
what we're going to be doing
to the left we have the app development
side
this is a full stack javascript
application used for the demo
and code is committed directly to a mono
repo in github
on the other side we have a lenode
account
and two servers running in lenode these
are called lynodes
in that interface
one of them is running jenkins
also known as the jenkins controller
and the other server is using docker to
run our application
the jenkins controller will be
configured to watch the github repo and
when it pulls and sees changes it will
initiate the cicd process in one of the
agents
the agents will run all of the steps in
the pipeline
to check out the code from the branch we
designate in github
run tests and deploy
if everything was successful
if the pipeline fails for any reason it
will immediately stop and of course not
deploy the application
and either way we can see the build
results and the logs in the main jenkins
controller
the first step is to sign up for a
lenode account
if you are a first-time user of lenode
when you sign up for an account they
will give you a 50 credit
that is good for the first 60 days for
you to try out
that will be more than enough to follow
along with everything that we are doing
in this tutorial
you can sign up for your account with
whatever service provider you want or
using your email
i already have an account so i'm going
to skip to the dashboard view
you can see i have some servers already
running here that i used for testing
in this left-hand menu you can see the
services that lenode has to offer from
lenodes
which are servers that you can spin up
volumes for storage
other things like firewalls
if you want to connect your domains
they also have an object storage
solution
for things like images or static
resources
similar to using aws s3
and a marketplace
that gives you one-click installs for a
lot of popular solutions
we are going to be using a couple apps
from this marketplace in the tutorial
today
you can see i clicked marketplace and it
went ahead and took me through
to create a new node
select a marketplace and shows me all of
the options here
the first server that i am going to
create
is one that's already set up with
jenkins
if you were installing jenkins yourself
you would have a couple options
to install directly or use their
official docker container
the lenode marketplace option here just
installs it directly on the server that
we're going to spin up
i'm going to scroll down
to more options it gives me the option
for the linux distro now depending on
what option you choose here
in the marketplace which one of these
you choose
you're going to see different options
available down here
for the jenkins container these are the
ones i have to select
i'm going to see what's available right
now it's only debian 10 that's available
for this jenkins server
and now i need to select a region
i'm just going to select the region
closest to me
in new jersey usa
and then i need to select what kind of
server
by default it'll show you all of the
options with dedicated cpus
how many cpus how much ram
and these are a little bit more
expensive for this tutorial i'm just
going to use the cheapest one the nano
one gigabyte
which if you look at the jenkins
documentation is more than enough to
run jenkins
so i'm going to choose this
scroll down
this is the name
this lenode label is the name
that you saw in that first table view
so i'm going to give it the name
free code
camp
jenkins
you can optionally add tags here
about the type of servers the
technologies
or something else you want to
differentiate between the nodes that you
spin up
i'm just going to leave it blank
and now i can choose a root password
this password that i enter here
is something i can use when i ssh into
the server
i can also add an ssh key and ssh with
the key
i'm just going to generate
a root password here
so i'm going to use my password manager
which is bit warden
i'm going to come down to generator
it generated this unique password it's
30 characters i'll be deleting this
server after the tutorial so
don't need anything crazy let me do 10
characters
copy
and
paste
i'm not going to add an ssh key for this
i'll just use the password
i do want to be sure i saved the
password though so what i like to do is
come in here
i'm gonna add
this username and password let me paste
in the password
and then i called the lenode free
codecamp jenkins so i'll just put that
in the username
save it and then i have the password
stored
so i can copy it later when i go to ssh
i don't need any of these options
i can go ahead and hit create
it will take a minute it says
provisioning
while that's going i'm going to create a
second linode
now for the second one i could just
create a custom one
but i'm going to go ahead and use their
marketplace again
and create one with docker already
installed and set up so i'm going to use
their
docker lenode from the marketplace
i clicked on that
and scroll down for the options
so now you can see i have special
options for the docker server
for this i'm going to leave these
options blank
instead of using an ssh key again i'm
just going to use a password
and i'll select
the latest debian 11
region again i'll do newark new jersey
shared cpu nano
and
this is the server where i'm going to
host and run my application
so i'm going to say free code camp
application for the root password i'm
gonna do the same thing
generate a password
copy
enter
and then i'll go ahead and
add that password
create
that's provisioning if i go back to my
list
my free codecamp jenkins is up and
running
and this one should be done in a minute
now let's check out our running instance
of jenkins
you can go into the jenkins server i
just spun up
and i can actually access the running
instance of jenkins at this ip address
i'm going to go ahead and do that
it should be at port 8080
and usually when you would pull this up
you would see a login screen but because
this is our first time it's prompting us
to enter a password
now this password we will have to get
from this file when we ssh into our
server
i'm going to go ahead and do that
copy this
ssh
now i can ssh into the node
and it's asking for my password
since i didn't set up a key for this
instance
so i'm going to go ahead and use
password authentication
and i did save it in my password manager
so i'll go ahead and copy the password
i'll enter in here
and now i'm inside the server
so let me go back to jenkins and it said
to copy the password from this file
let me take a look at that
i'm going to cat that file
and that prints out the contents so now
i can
copy this password
now if i go back to the browser
and i can just paste that password here
click continue
and since i'm just setting it up for the
first time it's asking what plugins i
want to start with
you can either do this manually or if
you're just getting started with jenkins
it's probably best to install the
suggested plugins you can always add or
remove plugins later
but as you're using jenkins you'll
realize that a lot of plugins depend on
other plugins
and these suggested plugins just give
you a good base to start with
so i'm going to click on that
it's installing
this takes a few minutes
now i can create the first admin user
i'm going to call this
jenkins
fcc and now i need a password
i'll go ahead and generate this password
just a short simple password
copy it
i'm going to just use a dummy email
address here
jenkins fcc at
this is just a public email address
provider
and before i go i'm actually going to
save
this user
the username
there we go
so i'm going to click save and continue
i don't have a domain or another
configuration so i'll leave this how it
is right now
i can always access it via this ip at
port 8080 so i'm going to save and
finish
and now jenkins is ready to start using
next let's do a quick tour of the
jenkins interface
to start you can see they have this top
navigation
and then also this sidebar to the left
i'm going to start off with the top
since it's a lot simpler
so first i have this jenkins fcc that's
my username
so this is just a quick link to my user
profile
and go back
and i also can see any notifications or
warnings or error messages
linked here
because i clicked on it it took me to my
settings page
i'm going to go back for now and come
back here in a minute
go back to dashboard
and starting from the top
if i click on new item you can see this
is a quick link to create
a freestyle project or a pipeline so if
i want to create jobs i can come here
and do that
i'll come back here to do that in a
minute
notice whenever i go into
one of these navigation items
you can see i get breadcrumbs here
where i can navigate back up
this people navigation item just lets me
manage any users that have access to
this jenkins
right now i just have the one admin user
but really you might have devops and
developers and other people
with different levels of access to this
interface
and you can actually give quite
fine-grained permissions on
what they can or cannot do
build history
will display information and feedback of
the jobs that we run
we'll be coming back to that later as
well
i'm going to skip down to views now
you can see there's nothing in
this views page yet
this is basically a dashboard view of
all of your jobs
and you can also use this new view link
to create
kind of custom dashboards for
viewing different kinds of jobs or maybe
for different users to see different
information
so i'm going to go back to dashboard
now i save manage jenkins for last
because this is where all of the
configuration and
plugins key management
this is the page we will be spending
most of our time on initially
to set everything up so that we can
create pipelines and run jobs
first at the top
you can see that it will let you know
when there is a new version of jenkins
available
actually this is a little bit out of
date or the version that i have in this
lenode is out of date anyway
so it's letting me know
and you can see if i scroll down at the
bottom here it says the current version
that i have
which i believe is like maybe 25 minor
versions out of date so
i do need to go into my server and
update that
if i want to see information about my
current version of jenkins
there is an about jenkins section
in this manage jenkins dashboard which
will take me to a page that also shows
my version and information about
the version of jenkins that i'm using
i'm going to go back
now some of the main settings here
are your settings to
globally
configure different things about jenkins
and also paths this configuration page
will let you manage a lot of the core
settings and features of jenkins as well
as give you
setting options
for some of the plugins that you install
i'm not going to touch any of these
things right now
i'm just going to leave them as the
default
go back to manage jenkins
manage plugins
this is where we can
search for
install or
update plugins or even remove plugins
that we don't need
we can do all that from here i'll come
back here in a minute because we will be
installing a few more plugins
i'll go back
managing nodes
see we have the default node which is
the controller
now to start i will be running some jobs
on this default built-in node
which is good for trying things out and
getting started but it is recommended
that you create nodes just for running
jobs
and then use this default built-in as
the controller
without running jobs on this node itself
we'll come back to
that the other important area that i'm
going to point out
is this manage credentials
when you create other nodes that are
going to be able to run jobs
you will need to add credentials here to
give those nodes permission to
access whatever resources they need to
and for the controller to communicate
with the nodes
this is a very simple overview
of the jenkins interface
next i'm going to add a few plugins and
then there's going to be another
part of
the interface called blue ocean to
demonstrate
i want to point out here that
jenkins
has kind of a dated look and feel
but it is completely
customizable
you can use a theme plugin
use a theme
built by somebody else or create your
own
css and javascript
to make this look and feel however you
want
i'm not going to be installing a theme
but i will be installing kind of a new
ui
section
of this jenkins interface to manage
pipelines which is called like i
mentioned blue ocean
now i'm in the plugin manager
and you can see the tabs here
updates are for the plugins that
i already have and have available
updates
so i could come and select plugins i
want to update
and click download now and it will
install the update after i restart
jenkins
which as i'm downloading it does give me
the option if i want to go ahead and
restart jenkins
i'm going to deselect these
available is just a list of plugins
that i can check off and install as well
i'm going to come back to this i can see
the plugins that i already have
in this installed tab
and advanced is some options that i'm
not going to look at right now
so let me go back to available
actually i'm going to go ahead and
filter here
and first i'm going to look for
blue ocean
you can see there are several
plugins here
i'm going to go ahead and install the
main blue ocean plugin
i'm going to say download now and
install after restart
it is in the process of downloading and
installing
you can see and i'm going to check this
box at the bottom if you can see it says
restart jenkins
when
installation is complete so now it says
jenkins is going to shut down
it will just take a minute for jenkins
to restart now
you can see that this restarting jenkins
is running
now that it's finished
i can log back in
so i'm going to go back to the plugin
section and manage jenkins manage
plugins
and i'm going to go to available
and this time i'll filter by docker
so
this first option
is the main docker plug-in
and there is a second one
for docker compose
i'm going to do the same thing
and download now and install after
restart
you can see that
some of the plugins have dependencies of
other plugins like i just
the only ones i selected were actually
this docker one and the docker compose
one
but because they have dependencies of
docker api and docker commons
jenkins is also installing those plugins
so it will install the plugin you select
as well as any dependent plugins
if they aren't installed already
this is going to take a few minutes to
install these
now that we installed those plugins
you will see some additional options in
some of the settings pages in jenkins
and you can also see this new sidebar
item saying open blue ocean
let me click on that
you can see this is a completely
different interface
because it's a modern ui
for pipeline management in jenkins
it's still linked to the old interface
so if you click on some links here like
administration you can see it takes you
back to the old interface
because blue ocean doesn't have a
managed jenkins section
let me go back to blue ocean you can
also
click this kind of exit icon
and that takes you back to the regular
jenkins dashboard
normally you would see a list of the
pipelines you create here
but since there are no pipelines it
gives us this box prompting us to create
a new pipeline
so that's what we're going to do next
let me start by creating a new pipeline
it's asking where my repository is
hosted
which is github
and in order to connect to my repository
and be able to run jobs
i need to
[Music]
use my github access token so i need to
create one
this warning in red here is just because
i had previously created an access token
you probably will not see this
i'm going to come here to create an
access token
it will take me to
my github account
and i can go straight to the page
where i can create an access token
if you want to get here
on your own you can access this page
through settings and developer settings
and then personal access tokens
you can see that by clicking on the link
the necessary permissions that i'm going
to need for jenkins
are already pre-populated and selected
here
so i don't need to change anything
i just need to
give a name to my personal access token
and then i can also change the
expiration if i want
this is just a name so when i look
through my tokens in github i can know
what the token is for
i won't be using this name anywhere in
jenkins
i'll just be using the token itself
so everything else is set already and
i'm going to go ahead and generate the
token
the token does disappear if i leave this
page
so i'm going to go ahead and copy it
and now that it's created
i can go back over to
jenkins and enter it here
and click connect
so that worked
and now that i'm connected to the github
account with my access token
it shows me the list of all the
organizations that i belong to
and i'm going to select the faraday
academy organization
because that's where the rebuild i want
to use is located
and in that organization
it shows me all 14 repos and i'm going
to be using the curriculum app for this
tutorial
and then i just hit create pipeline
now it takes me to this interactive
pipeline creator screen and you can see
a message just popped up that said no
jenkins file located
so let me just go to the project in
github so you can see what it's talking
about
and in this repo in github
you can see there is no file called
jenkins file
so by
default jenkins
will look for a file called jenkins file
in the root directory
of a repository
now what a jenkins file is is a file
that
contains
instructions for a pipeline written as
code
so you can read
the file and see each step
defined in the pipeline going from top
to bottom divided into
stages and steps
which we'll talk about in a minute
now because this is a file it's checked
into git and versioned
and can be managed or rolled back
just like any other file in git
now since the file doesn't already exist
in our repository
when we create the pipeline in blue
ocean
and save for the first time
it will automatically create a new
jenkins file for us and commit it to the
repository
so let's go through that process now
back in jenkins
you can see the message down at the
bottom here saying
a stage is required
basically the pipeline is broken down
into stages
which are like sections
every stage has to have at least one
step
and the steps are what contain the
scripts
calls to
jenkins plugins
or other actionable tasks
to be carried out in the pipeline
both stages and steps
can be run in parallel
or one after the other
you will see this as we go along in the
pipeline creator
i'm going to name this stage something
like checkout code
and now i need to add steps
so i'm going to add a step here
and find the get plugin that i installed
earlier
and it's asking for the url of my git
repo
so let me grab that
paste it
and i need to denote which branch i'm
using
for the repo i use dev as the default
branch
so i'm going to use that
and now i can click save
it says that saving this pipeline will
commit a jenkins file to the repository
which is exactly what i want
and since there is no jenkins file of
course it will create a new one for us
i'm going to
leave the description blank so it will
just give me a default commit message
and it's pointing to dev so it's going
to commit directly to the dev branch
so let me save and run that
and it
failed the first time it was trying to
run sometimes it passes on the second
try so let me retry
and it failed again so let me look at
the logs
and it says that
the recommended get tool is none
it gives me some information here on
what's going wrong and why it's failing
it's saying that git does not exist
basically i spun up this server
using jenkins from the lenode
marketplace
but that server does not have git
pre-installed on it
so i will need to install that directly
on my instance
and since i don't have any kind of
automated setup for the instance i'm
just going to ssh directly into it
so in lenode i'm going to go to my
server
and instead of using my own terminal
this time i'm going to use the built-in
one that they provide in the node
it's called lish so i can click launch
lish console
and it prompts me to log in here
so ignore the
previous incorrect logins i'm going to
log in as root
and then grab the password
that i saved in my password manager
and i successfully sshed in
let me make sure that git is not
installed i can do that with the get
dash version command
and it's telling me that git is not
found
so before i install it i'm going to do
an apt update
to make sure i have the latest versions
of the packages
it's telling me that
i can upgrade
some of the packages i already have
installed or they have new versions
but i'm not going to do that right now
for now i'm just going to do apt install
git
it's asking me if i want to continue
installing
38.3 megabytes
and now i should have get installed
so let me check again
and yes i have git version 2.20
and now that i have git installed
i'm going to try to rerun my pipeline
over here
while it's running notice that the
colors change
so
you have the color blue
while it's running
and then you can see things turn green
as they pass
and then when everything passes this
whole thing turns green
as you've seen before red
means failure
and there's also a yellow state
for certain cases like test failure
then it can turn yellow so everything is
very visual here and
you can see that now it passes
since i have the correct dependencies
installed on the server
so this is the most basic version of a
pipeline to create in jenkins
so let me add a few more steps now
now when jenkins created this pipeline
as i mentioned before
it also created a jenkins file
so when i refresh my
github here
it added the jenkins file and you can
see where it says added jenkins here
that is the default commit message
because we didn't type in a custom one
and you can see if we go into the
jenkins file
this is the stage that we created and
the step to check out code
with the github plugin
jenkins files are usually pretty easy to
read because you can see well-named
options
like
which agent you are running the pipeline
on
a list of
stages and then
the steps inside of each stage
and for the github plugin here i'm using
the api that they provide
and passing in the github url for the
repo and which branch i want to check
out
so let's explore the interface a little
bit and then try to update our pipeline
from the top left
you can see which pipeline is running i
only have one right now
if i click on it i can see the history
of the jobs that have run
and the ending state if they
passed failed or are still running
and if i go into one of them
i can see that it has all the
information
i don't have any changes yet
and i don't have testing that really
runs and you can see the fourth tab is
for any artifacts
that are produced so
if i click on this file
this is just automatically created by
jenkins is not something i explicitly
have to create
but if we did create some kind of output
it would be here with the artifacts on
this page
the next icon here
that looks like refresh
will re-run any jobs
with the pencil i can edit the pipeline
if i click on the gear icon it takes me
to settings in the old jenkins ui
it takes me directly to the settings for
this pipeline
and also here if i go to branches
and hover over any of the branches in
the list here
then i get a couple icons here
and one of them is edit
so i'm going to go ahead and click on
that edit icon
now there's different ways to arrange a
pipeline
i can add more stages
i can go back to
the previous stage and add more steps
or i can
add stages that run in parallel
depending on what i want to do
now there are a lot of options
for different types of things that i can
do in a step
some of these like docker and git are
from plugins that i've installed
i'm just going to use the regular shell
script here
and for right now
i'm just going to list contents of the
directory and this will show up in the
jenkins logs
it's going to create another commit
to update the jenkins file
so i'm going to add a commit message
this time
and i'll save and run that
and if i go over to my app
i can see that
next to the jenkins file it shows the
new commit message
and go into the jenkins file and
the new
stage and
step is updated
i guess i forgot to name my stage i
thought it was required
you can see in jenkins here that when i
make updates it's running twice
that's because
i am committing
with the jenkins file directly to the
dev branch so that runs but there is
also an open pr in my
repository
this pr 90
and i'm making the pr into dev every
time i'm updating the jenkins file it's
re-running all of the pr's
so let me go into here
and it's passing
it defaulted to the name error here
but anyway i can see that
it printed everything out
let me change that name error
so let me rename the stage to log and
save that
of course now it's going to run again
even though i'm just updating
the
wording in the jenkins file
one thing to note here is that services
like github do have restrictions on api
usage
so if you start to see failing jobs here
it might not be because of anything
you've done wrong in jenkins
but you might have hit the limit
with the github api
and then you'll either have to upgrade
your account or wait until it resets i
think it resets every hour
so sometimes jobs fail because of a cap
on api usage
but here it looks like everything went
fine
so now i want to add another script to
the pipeline
i'm going to come to branches and click
edit again
and i have this simple log script
but let me just run one in parallel so
you can see how the jenkins file works
i'm going to call this front end unit
test
add a step here another shell script
and i'm going to paste in the command
i'm going into the curriculum front
directory
where my front end is and then run an
npm install to install the dependencies
and then run npm run test unit so run
the unit test
and i'll click save there
so this is going to run and i'll follow
it here i think it is going to fail
because i don't actually have node or
npm installed on my lenode server
so it failed let me look at the logs
and indeed it says npm not found
so let me go back to lenode
and launch the lish console
again and i'm still logged in from last
time
so instead of
app install this time
i'm going to install
node via the recommended command with
curl
this is for
version 16.
you don't only have to use version 16
but this is just the version that i
tested it with it's a stable version
it's giving me more instructions here
to apt-get install
node
so i'm going to enter that command
and now i'm going to check the node
version
it says version 16 and let me check the
npm version
because npm comes with node
and i have version 8 of npm
so that should be all i need here
let me try to rerun this now
all the other steps passed this one's
still going
it hasn't failed yet so that's a good
sign
while it's running i'm going to switch
over to github
and go to the jenkins file
and you can see that
now it adds this parallel command
and denotes that these two stages are
running in parallel
and gives it
the title of
the first stage for both
and then each stage
in parallel has its own title and
steps
of course you could just put this in one
stage and have two steps as well
but i just wanted to show how it works
to run things in parallel in jenkins
this is taking a little while so i'm
going to fast forward
so i actually re-ran this because i
closed that other screen
you can see that everything passed this
time including the new one for tests
that i added
now that we have a couple basic scripts
working let's add some stages so that we
can finally deploy the app to docker hub
now i'm going to add a build step to our
pipeline
i'm just going to create a new stage
called build
and then i can add a regular shell
script
i'm going to use the shell script to run
docker commands
so i'll use the regular docker build
command
to build a docker image
from this docker file that i'm pointing
to
because the docker file isn't in the
root directory here it's in a
subdirectory so i need to point to that
with this dash f flag
and i also have to
let docker
know what is my current context
which in this case is the directory i'm
already in so i'm just using the period
here
and now i'm going to commit this
now it's building and i'm waiting for it
to build
i re-recorded this a few times so you
can see the numbers skip around a little
bit
but i'm still going through each step in
the process
now that the build passed
i need two more steps to be able to
deploy this to docker home
first i need to log in
with my docker hub credentials
to make sure i'm authorized
to push images to my docker hub account
to do that i need to use the docker
login command
and the default place that it points to
is dockerhub so i don't have to do
anything special here
but i do need to use my credentials like
my username and password
but of course i don't want to store my
username and password for docker hub
in the jenkins file
so i am going to
use variables
in jenkins
so i'm going to add environment
variables to my pipeline
and then i will just
point to those variables
from my jenkins file
so you can see i can add the docker hub
user
and the docker hub password i'm going to
just add those values in blue ocean
if you aren't using blue ocean or you
want to use the standard jenkins
interface there is also a key manager
in the settings over there i think it's
a bit easier to do directly in blue
ocean here
of course i'm not going to show
these variables on screen you'll have to
enter in your own credentials here
and now i'm building and testing just to
make sure that my login worked
[Music]
and indeed it passed
the only thing left to do is to add a
new stage here to actually push my
updated image to docker hub
so i'm going to add another shell script
and this time i'll use the docker push
command
i just need to add
the name of the container
and optionally the tag
but the only tag i have right now is the
default latest tag
so i'm just going to leave that
and it failed because it says that an
image does not exist
so with my username and the name of that
image
now
since i already
built and deployed this app a few years
ago
i already have this in my docker hub
however now that i
want to push a new image from jenkins
i need to
tag it during the build step here
so i'm going to add a tag to my build
script
and i can just use the dash t
option
and i'm going to tag it with the same
name that i'm using so my username
and then curriculum front and i'll just
add latest
now let me save and run that and see if
it passes
and it passed and pushed correctly to
dockerhub
let me check over in my docker hub
interface
it's at
hub.docker.com
and i'm already logged in
so i can see that my
curriculum app
was updated
less than a minute ago or rather my
curriculum front app which is just the
front end
congratulations on making it to the end
of this video tutorial i hope you were
able to learn a lot about
jenkins and devops and lenode
as always if you have questions or
comments please leave them in the
comments section below
i hope you are also able to check out
the follow along readme that is linked
in the description
it has all of the instructions
for of course following along with every
step in this video as well as some notes
that i took along the way about things
that i learned in the process of
creating this tutorial
i want to thank lenode once again
for their grant to free code camp and
making educational content like this
video possible
i hope all of you have a great rest of
your week
and we'll see you in the next video